happy to be here and to share with you
what I actually personally I've been
working on for the last 13 years of my
life first as a grad student at Cal Tech
and now is a co-founder of soul seemed
energy so there is a I have a demo which
I'll show at the end there is a computer
in here so you know it's not too far of
a stretch we are an energy harvesting
company and so I'm going to talk to you
about thermoelectrics specifically
materials that convert heat to
electricity and as Andy said these are
enabling low power electronic devices of
the future whether it's a wearable or in
and out of things device and so I'm
going to walk you through the story of
the last 13 years of my life you know
I'll try to make it exciting we'll start
off with you know how this how I got
started and then again I was a grad
student in the lab working in the field
of thermoelectrics we'll talk about you
know how how was that this turned into a
startup and how we've sort of managed to
get our to get out of what's called the
valley of death here in the value for
most startups and into viability what we
believe is now a viable business let me
start off by saying something very
obvious that energy is important and I'm
not going to bore you with you know
we've all seen like the Sun yeah you
know sends enough photons in in one hour
that we can that we can use it for an
entire year if we needed to I mean we've
seen all these statistics I just want to
make the point that everything that's
living is basically a transducer of
energy you know takes an input it of
some form transduces it into something
else and gives you an output so this
gentleman I don't know what not really
sure he's pointing out but my
two-year-old son his inputs are you know
peanut butter and fish and a lot of
knows from his mom and dad and his
outputs are kind of I'll do whatever I
want you know every living thing is
hands do sir of energy and the point is
every thing that living things create
are also part of this paradigm I mean
since we are just transducers we
interact with our world with inputs and
outputs I'm going to go a little one
slide here a little off track this is I
think just one of the most amazing
organs of the body the human ear and you
know we'll just I'll just walk you
really quickly how this transduces
acoustic energy to an audio signal in
your brain you have the outer ear the
audio you know the acoustic waves hit
the tympanic membrane which is the
eardrum and then there are these amazing
three small bones in your ear and they
basically act as like a little hammer
that your drum bangs on one of the bones
the male eous and that transmits the
energy to the stay peas which is kind of
like a hammer that hits a liquid-filled
part of the year called the cochlea and
what's so amazing about this is if you
were to if you didn't have those bones
and you just tried transmitting acoustic
signals directly to the liquid filled
cochlea you'd have an amazing impedance
impedance mismatch and I'll huge loss of
energy and so evolution has developed
this incredible you know exquisite
transformation impedance matching with
these three tiny bones and then what's
what's even more phenomenal is in the
cochlea you have these hair cells and as
a liquid moves the hair cells generate
the hair cells move in as a response to
the different frequencies from the
acoustic signal those hair cells give
off neurotransmitters that stimulate the
auditory nerve and that sends an action
potential to your brain and then beyond
that we don't even know what happens
right i mean the brain does its own
signal processing it's just it's
unbelievable I mean right I mean you
look at this and it's like wow this is
just one sensor of among five right
taste smell touch sight
common man made transducers these are
the ones that are sort of you know the
most common to transduce some sort of
input into useful electrical energy that
we use today ACG naturally producing AC
generator AC generating devices are
steam turbines right developed long time
ago piezoelectric the DC ones as we know
batteries solar cells thermoelectrics
it's interesting there's I'm going to be
talking about thermoelectrics obviously
for the majority this talk but if you
look at all these one of the out
lighters is the battery the battery is a
self-contained device that needs to be
recharged it eventually ends up going
you know dead it depletes whereas every
other device as long as I'm providing
motion to my piezo it's going to work as
long as i provide steam to my turban
it's it's you know it's always going to
be moving solar as long as there's light
it's going to it's going to it's going
to turn on and as long as their heat for
the thermoelectric it's going to
generate power but the battery
eventually will will die and so the
reason is that as you all know is it
simple right simple chemistry right it's
filled with a bunch of chemicals lithium
cobalt oxide is the most common lithium
gets depleted and the only way to
recharge the battery is to use an outlet
so we've got wires sticking everywhere
you know for our phones or laptops it's
really annoying so what if there is a
way to eliminate the fact that you have
to charge everything with an outlet and
the answer is there is of course depends
on the application and how much power
you need but the human body is a is at
rest is about a hundred watts this is an
incandescent light bulb this is actually
from the Livermore fire station this is
the oldest running incandescent light
bulb in the world this is more than a
hundred years in operation believe it or
not without actually having ever been
replaced we're about a hundred watts
the light bulb and when we're exercising
we're a kilowatt so there's a lot of
heat that the body gives off that we're
wasting and we can use some of that heat
with a thermoelectric that's the idea to
basically charred to recharge your
battery so that you never have to plug
in your you know let's say wearable
device into into a wall outlet so what
is it what exactly is a thermoelectric a
thermoelectric is just a transducer that
takes heat input and generates
electricity so you've got a temperature
differential from some heat source that
creates a voltage and it works in
Reverse if I Supply electrical power to
the thermoelectric I can make one side
cold and I can use that for
refrigeration and the way it's assembled
this is kind of like a cutaway it's got
N and P semi conductor elements that are
connected electrically in series and if
you notice they're all thermally in
parallel so one side is hot for example
in one side is cold so there there's
their thing you know the heat flux all
of these blue p NN semi conductor
elements are seeing a heat flux
longitudinally and they're all
electrically connected in series so that
you can maximize the amount of voltage
that you get out each one provides a
certain voltage for a certain
temperature drop thermoelectrics have
enabled a lot of things maybe some of
you guys drive cars that have car seats
that cool some of these are some of the
luxury cars they're actually getting a
lot more popular this is an image taken
by Voyager 1 from about I think four
billion miles away from Earth that
little tiny tiny dot you can see it's
right there as the earth and yeah it
makes Donald Trump look small this was a
Carl Sagan have the the NASA team
rotated around to take this picture to
kind of put everything in perspective
voyagers are basically powered by
thermal a radioisotope nuclear-powered
thermoelectric generator so a piece of
plutonium inside the set of the
spacecraft heats up a thermoelectric and
I think in this case it's based on
silicon germanium
and this thing's been operational since
Ashwin was Voyager launched it was semi
Thanks thank you and it's I think just
recently confirmed that it was you know
the first man-made object that vacated
the solar system which is pretty
remarkable but again this is this
picture as possible due to
thermoelectric mars the Curiosity rover
on Mars is a thermoelectric powered it's
almost I've seen it at JPL before they
launched it in 2012 2012 it basically
was as big as a car almost it's huge and
you can't put enough you know you solar
panels solar panels will be too
prohibitive they'd have to be enormous
because this thing is really power
hungry so they used a thermoelectric and
it's still you know it's been there for
years and still going a thermoelectric
in essence is really just a heat engine
you know it's it's a thermodynamic heat
engine it's there's a hot reservoir the
hot side and a cold reservoir the cold
side and it does work it takes some heat
in some part of that work part of that
heat gets turned into work and some of
the then heat is expelled through the
cold reservoir and you know in a steam
turbine the working fluid is steam here
it's just electrons I mean that's really
the only difference and since this is
kind of you know csee crowd just look at
the circuit diagram and you know we can
derive a few useful equations so if I
take a thermoelectric material that has
a temperature gradient the
thermoelectric material itself has its
own internal resistance and I attached
it to a load the voltage that's
generated is equal to s times delta T
Delta T's being that is of course the
temperature difference s is the Seebeck
coefficient which is just the ratio of
the voltage to the temperature drop the
larger that number is the larger the
voltage the efficiency of this device is
the work output w divided by the heat
that's needed to create the temperature
difference q the work extractive of
course is at the resistive load which is
the current times the voltage across the
load of course this is a simple
Rizzo series a resistive divider circuit
to two resistors 11 being the load one
being the thermoelectric and you can
work through all these equations i guess
i won't bore you too much but the work
is just proportional to s squared the
Seebeck coefficient squared the heat
input is interesting is consists of
three terms one is just the natural flow
of heat across the temperature drop due
to the thermal conductivity of the
material the pelletier there's a
pelletier term is t hot and a Joule
heating term that actually has a
negative sign in front of it because it
actually counteracts the other two so it
fights against them and if you rearrange
a few things and maximize for the
efficiency you get this complicated
looking equation but if you remember
from thermodynamics ZT is and we'll talk
about that in the next slide is this
dimensionless figure of Merit if this is
equal to infinity this entire term here
goes to 1 and if you remember from
thermodynamics the efficiency of a
Carnot engine is just Delta T over T hot
that's the maximum efficiency that you
can get so the name of the game in
thermoelectrics is to maximize Z T there
is no theoretical reason why it can't be
infinity you'd like it to be as large as
possible so you can get the largest
efficiency from the conversion of heat
to electricity and it consists of three
material parameters and these are the
three material parameters that makes
this field of thermoelectric so
challenging to work in because they're
not mutually independent and so as I
mentioned is the Seebeck coefficient
otherwise known as a thermal power it's
the ratio of the voltage out / the
temperature in the larger that number is
obviously the better right if I could
get like a thousand volts for one degree
temperature drop that would be fantastic
typically they're on the hundreds of
micro volt per Kelvin on that order the
Sigma is the electrical conductivity I
need a material that is super super
conductive because i don't want Joule
heating losses if you remember that
third term it's a Joule heating term I
want to minimize the loss there and
Kappas the thermal conductivity I need
that to be very low and that's why it's
in the denominator because I need them
maintain a temperature differential so
if you look at these three terms in a
metal a metal as you all know is a very
good conductor of electrons but it's
also a very good conductor of heat it's
really really hard to decouple these
terms from each other so if i increase
sigma i typically increase kappa if i
increase s i typically decrease Sigma
for other reasons that we won't go into
it's incredibly hard to you know
untangle these terms and this number has
kind of hovered at room temperature it's
kind of hovered at 0.8 and we'll get to
that materials called bismuth all right
we'll get to in a few slides but that's
kind of the maximum ZT that's kind of at
room temperature that you can you can
buy commercially so how does heat give
you an electrical output well it just
moves electrons from hot to cold and the
way does that is you can think of the
electrons classically as a gas right so
as you all know when you heat a gas the
gas particles tend to diffuse away from
the heat source and the gas expands
right they have a lot of they absorb a
lot of thermal energy they have a lot of
their velocity increases and so they
diffuse away and that's exactly what
happens a heat source basically creates
a voltage differential because the
electrons go from hot to cold you know
classically speaking is very very simple
right and that Seebeck coefficient that
i mentioned again is just Delta V
divided by delta T so how do you
maximize the Seebeck coefficient well
let's take a look excuse me at a metal
if you remember from physics a metal
consists of a lot of electrons that are
free to move around but they're only
free to move around at the Fermi surface
and so when you excite an electron in a
metal through the introduction of heat
that's that little red sliver there on
this metal fermi service each electron
has about Katie of energy thermal energy
is like Katie right that's boltzmann
constant times the temperature turns out
that the Seebeck coefficient of you if
you just you
no look at your thermodynamic properties
is just the entropy per electron charge
the entropy is the heat Q divided by the
temperature divided by the electron
charge that's the Seebeck coefficient
and so the heat as i said is Katie so
you plug in katy for q the t's cancel
and you get k / e but in a metal only
the electrons at the Fermi surface are
allowed to to move all the other metals
below the work function are kind of
trapped in the valence bonds of the of
the metal atoms and so you have to
normalize that by kt over EF and so if
you this is again a kind of a zeroth
order approximation if you run the
numbers right K is just a is a constant
T is I plugged in room temperature EF
you know use a typical work function for
a metal let's say five EV or whatever
that's roughly a micro volt per Kelvin
tiny tiny voltage for a one degree
temperature differential micro volt is
not going to do is not going to do you a
lot of good so are there other materials
that we can look at that will give us
larger Seebeck coefficients because
remember we need a large Seebeck
coefficient well it turns out for a
semiconductor it's different than a
metal semiconductor can be doped and if
let's say it's doped and type and you've
got a lot of some electrons in the
conduction band well it's Fermi surface
is a lot smaller but all the electrons
can move around because it's they're all
in the conduction band they're dope that
way and so there is no normalization
term and you just you know each each
electron can you boots katie of energy
and at room temperature that translates
into about 100 micro volt per kelvin so
it's better it's about tourism magnitude
better than a metal it's again not a
whole lot right it's not it's not volts
like like a let's say the lithium ion
battery right is you know 3.7 volts but
it's still better than a metal so most
thermoelectrics as you'll see are based
on most commercial thermoelectrics are
based on semiconductors for this for
this particular reason and others let's
look at the thermal conductivity you
want a low thermal conductivity well how
do you do that if you guys remember from
you know Hookes law you have a mass on a
spring and just
imagine a crystalline lattice the atoms
are all sort of connected by bonds and
you can model the bonds as a spring
there's a spring constant K and each
atom has a mass m the velocity the speed
of sound and that solid is just a square
root of K over m again just from Hookes
law again 20 thora right this is an
approximation but I think it works well
in a material like bismuth an alloy of
bismuth telluride well business holler
right turns out is one of the world's
best thermoelectrics and alloys of it at
room temperature and the reason for that
is bismuth is a really really heavy
metal in fact it's the heaviest excuse
me it's a it's a semi metal it's the
heaviest element on the periodic table
before you know the elements after it
are all radioactive so it's the last
heavy metal that's non radioactive and
when you put when you create an alloy of
bismuth and tellurium together you've
got the heavy mass from the bismuth but
you also have the fact that you have
different mass densities across your
material and if you think about a
vibrating string right let's say I had a
string up here and I just created a
standing wave on it and that's my you
know my my waveform of the the you know
acoustics motion if I tie another string
to it that has a different mass density
and I do the same thing the wave will
propagate really nicely in the first
part of the string until it hits the not
where it sees a different mass density
on a different string some of that
energy will be reflected back and that's
kind of like analogous to thermal
conductivity being lowered because some
of the heat flow basically bounces back
and so that's why alloys of bismuth
higher bismuth and tellurium are really
good turns out diamond which is a
crystalline form of carbon has the
highest thermal conductivity and the
reason for that is first of all carbon
atoms are very very strong covalent
bonds meaning k the the spring constant
is very stiff right those bombs are
really really strong and it's got a
carbon as you know has a very very low
or light mass and so its thermal
conductivity is very high you don't want
to use carbon for thermoelectric
the other thing that you want is
obviously high electrical conductivity
and turns out semiconductors are great
because you can dope them you can
actually grow this is a silicon ingot
being grown right in a row across key
process you can you basically put
silicon into a container and you put a
bunch of dopant atoms right if you want
an n-type you put phosphorus or arsenic
if you want a p-type you put boron or
aluminum you heat it up and you create a
big pool or ingot of the stuff and you
withdraw it and now you've controlled
you can control the electronic
properties as you all know incredibly
well right I mean that's what makes the
computer possible right so summer
conductors are the materials that are in
use for thermoelectrics for these
reasons and bismuth telluride is the
incumbent material because it can be
made to have good high electrical
connectivity and it also has a very low
thermal conductivity the problem with it
though is that it's brittle and very
expensive it's brittle when you try to
cut it or manipulate it in any way it
just flakes off and it's very expensive
because bismuth and tellurium are not
you know very common elements found in
the earth crust tolaram is rarer than
platinum so when I was a grad student I
had spent probably two years at Caltech
working on a material that was very
exotic and I wanted to make it into a
very good thermoelectric and you know I
wrote a nice little paper about it it
was it was a really long slog those two
years and I realized after that and this
might be some advice to grad students
right is you gotta really work on things
that are relevant if you want to make a
difference right i mean if you want to
be an academic that's fine i mean you
know you can publish papers and do do
that thing that's that's totally fine
but if you want to do something relevant
you have to work on materials that scale
that are economically you know relevant
and so I started looking at silicon and
I looked at the literature and there had
been some promising results with silicon
from a few years before before I got
started in this field silicon turns out
has a very high Seebeck coefficient so
it's about 54 and optimally doped
open concentration it's about 500 micro
volt per Kelvin which is actually pretty
high for our semiconductor it has
excellent electrical properties right it
can be doped you know very very highly
which is which is great the problem with
it the one problem with that is that has
a very high thermal conductivity so it
conducts heat like a metal you know it
conducts heat as good as aluminium
basically so I started looking at some
papers there had been some efforts
before my time where people have made
silicon nanowires and measure the
thermal conductivity and it turned out
that it dropped and so I wanted to
pursue this this research and lower
silicon thermal conductivity well it
turns out silicon has this amazingly I
mean sort of lucky property in the sense
that it has two different length scales
for its heat and for its electrons the
heat is mainly transported by phonons
which are just atomic vibrations it
turns out in silicon at room temperature
photons travel every 300 nanometers
before scattering but the electrons
travel 10 nanometers before scattering
and so there's a huge discrepancy in
length scales 300 nanometers for the
heat 10 nanometers for the electrons and
if you can create defects that are on a
length scale somewhere in between you
can force the phonons to scatter off
those defects at a higher rate and lower
the thermal conductivity whereas the
electrons because they're scattering
every 10 nanometers at a very short
distance they're basically blind to
those defects and so here's you know
cart a little cartoon these little blue
dots inside our bulk silicon material
here are defects the electron is this
green particle that just kind of whizzes
right through because it just doesn't
see them it's scattering every 10
nanometers anyway the phonons which
normally would whiz right through as
well because they have a much larger
scattering distance actually our end up
end up being forced to scatter into them
and so the heat slows down tremendously
the analogy and this is great analogy
that my co-founder came up with the heat
the phonons are like vans right and the
defects are traffic cones and the heat
is just basically bumping into these
traffic cones whereas the electrons are
your
little scooter motor bikes that just
whizzed right through they don't even
see the the traffic cones at all and so
what we did at Caltech when I was a grad
student is we made this really intricate
structure kind of almost like a mems
looking device this green array here you
can't really see the individual nano
nano wires in this false SEM image but
that green rectangular region is a bunch
of nanowires side by side 20 nanometers
in width and all these electrodes next
to it are just basically used to
interrogate the temperature the voltage
and all that so yeah I can measure ZT
that snake looking pattern is just a
heater so you can apply current through
it and through Joule heating creates a
temperature difference so you get the
point you you can make this really
intricate structure measure the silicon
nanowires thermoelectric properties and
turns out at about 20 nanometers the
thermal conductivity drops like a rock
and the defect in this case is the
boundary of the wire so the heat just
basically sees the boundary because it's
20 nanometers you know it likes to go
every 300 nanometers before bouncing off
something but here it's forced to bounce
off the boundary because of them the
width is only 20 nanometers and I just
have put things in perspective bulk
silicon has a thermal conductivity
that's about 120 watt per meter Kelvin
very high in a silicon animal nanowire
at this length scale it drops to nearly
1 watt per meter kelvins almost a
hundred fold decrease in the thermal
properties but remarkably the electrical
properties are unperturbed you can still
maintain high electrical fidelity
through this structure so looking at
this you can probably envisioned that
this would never be a manufacturable
process you know let alone you know
starters start the launch of a start-up
to try to try to make a wheel world
device from something looks like this
and so I went off after my PhD to the
University of Michigan in Ann Arbor and
I always you know I I wanted to take
this discovery that we that we had there
and figure out a way to scale this
process making manufacturable turn into
a company because I really thought this
was you know something there could be
something here so I had a group at
Michigan Michigan is just
the school it's it's not like your
typical ivory tower it's like Stanford
they're really they have a really
entrepreneurial spirit and I had a lot
of support for my colleagues we hit upon
a process that we felt was scalable and
my co-founder at the time he was just
graduating from Cal Tech as well he came
in Tanner Arbor lived in my basement and
we tried you know getting this process
up off the ground and that's where this
part of the talk is how this solution
got started and sort of the challenges
that we faced and how what we've
overcome in the last sort of four years
so so the first part was really that was
two thousand three to two thousand you
know even up to Michigan where we where
we first hit upon our first scalable
process 2011 eight years of my life when
we still on CH the company when my
co-founder came into my basement and we
started getting some good results we we
actually approached by vinod khosla
Stanford alum you guys I'm sure know who
he is just a visionary guy I mean he's a
high risk high risk tolerant looks at
you know he wants to do things that are
really big really impactful and you know
he just been just been a wonderful
person to us he gave us our first seed
funding to launch the company when we
thought we are our process was solved
and we could scale it up right away we
set up shop at Michigan's incubator this
used to be an old Pfizer building Pfizer
vacated it and Michigan bought it so if
you guys are looking to you know to move
on and and and you want to be a you know
you want to have maybe your own group
and you want to you want to do something
in entrepreneurial Michigan is a
fantastic place to do it in fact we even
got funding from the University through
their mints program which I think
predates anything at Stanford even had
going in terms of funding startups
spin-offs from the University so we set
up shop there and we you know obviously
with it with the idea of okay we have
this process that we think were
that's scalable how do we get it ready
for prime time and make a business out
of it and it turns out not only do you
have to do that obviously when you're
doing a start-up you have to figure out
what market you want your technology to
impact this this thermoelectric scan do
to do a lot of things right they can
they can go into automotive they can
recover waste heat from your car exhaust
and give you a boost in fuel efficiency
they can scavenge waste heat and a
factory and improve you know your your
bottom line in a factory they run in
Reverse as I mentioned before they can
do refrigeration and cooling they can do
wearables and IOT provide energy for
rechargeable batteries turns out that
the process the initial process when we
got started that we thought was scalable
wasn't we you know we had this process
as we sort of kept turning the crank we
figured out this was just going to be
too cost-prohibitive and we needed to
pivot and this is I think a common
thread among you know any any startup
right the growing pains that you
experience and really what you're doing
as a start-up is your auto is basically
looking to extend your runway right
that's that's something you hear a lot
your runway is basically how much cash
you have left in your in your account
and if you don't extend it you better be
you know ready to launch and so you
don't want ever want to be in a spot
where you're running out of cash and the
technology is not ready so after a hoops
after a another funding round and and
the great thing about the node is that
he told us to just do this you know take
your time figure it out don't rush into
a market with a technology that's not
ready that's just foolish but you see
this happen a lot with startups right
they go end or their investors want to
push them to go fast and and hard and
they end up going into the wrong market
right so we developed after a pivot
another process I have it here as a
black box i'm not going to go into the
details because of its
pyar tera nature but we're basically
today producing silicon devices that
have been certified by two independent
experts that are very high performance
we don't need a clean room to do this
we're not a solar process or a CMOS
process where defects are you know
having just one defect could kill your
transistor in fact defects in this case
are our friends as I showed you right
you want defects to basically impede the
flow of heat and we have about an eight
hour turnaround from wafer to actual
completed module device so so that's
great we figured out a process and now
we need to figure out okay what what
type of market do we want to attack it's
obvious that no one likes to recharge a
battery right that's a pain point I've
got an Apple watch I've got two charges
thing every day some of you I'm sure
have some some smart watches that you
wear and you've basically got to charge
the battery anywhere from a day to a few
weeks to maybe a month and the other
thing is that the battery if you look at
a lot of these devices whether it's an
Apple watch or it's a Fitbit or a pebble
or you know whatever it is right it's
almost always the batteries about half
the volume and that limits the amount of
functionality that an engineer can put
into the device because your space can
train because the battery so large so we
are after talking to a lot of customers
and this is something you have to do as
a start-up right you got to figure out
where the pain point is and what your
customer wants solved after talking to a
lot of different customers in the space
we think this is a great market get to
go into and we're actually taking
advantage of a convergence of a few
things the most important being that
electronics are getting are using are
utilizing less and less power so five
years ago this technology would not be
possible believe it or not MCU power
consumption was just too high so
TI back in two thousand four you know
you're looking at chips that are
operating in the hundreds of my cramps
per mega Hertz today you can buy MC use
that are down in the you know 30 micro
ampere megahertz range there are some
newer chips that are even that are
coming out there even lower which is
quite remarkable I mean you're you're
kind of actually getting close to the
fundamental you know limits of energy
consumption you know you're just you're
just going to eventually hit a wall
where you can't just like Moore's law
right you can't you can't just get free
energy right it's it's quite remarkable
and because of this fact we we can
leverage the company's low-power
computing chips and with our energy
harvesting technology power a you know a
pretty impressive suite of functions and
a SmartWatch it's there our
thermoelectric the best choice though
right that's another question I mean at
the end of day there's other energy
harvesting technologies out there for
example there's piezo-electric Sun
photovoltaics right to that come to mind
depending on the the way you construct
it in the application you can get
anywhere from the low microwave to even
milliwatts of power generation in a
piezo-electric if you put it in your
shoe and you step you can generate close
to a mill a lot of power in fact there's
somebody I don't know if it was in
Europe I forget but there's like a
sidewalk that somebody is so a sidewalk
and they put a bunch of piezo-electric
some people are just like stepping you
know just going about their day and
they're producing power to light I don't
know the street lighting or something I
i I'm not sure exactly what but it you
know you can actually create a lot of
power with piezo is depending on the
application for a wearable for Internet
of Things it's going to be difficult
right because for a wearable if it just
goes on my wrist just doing this is not
going to create a lot of power it's
going to create less than a micro watt
of power so pays electrics are out for
smartwatches and your typical sort of
Internet of Things sensors
photovoltaics what'll you know
photovoltaics are great the main problem
though is that you've got to be in
direct sunlight to get appreciable power
from a photovoltaic if you're in a room
like this and you're just barely at an
angle from from you know normal you're
producing a micro amp of current which
is just miniscule the great thing about
thermoelectrics is at and we have this
motto at the company as long as you're
alive the thermoelectric will work
you're giving off as I mentioned out you
know about 100 watts when you're at rest
when you're exercising you're giving off
a kilowatt there's a lot of heat coming
off your body the efficiency is really
really tiny remember these are heat
engines and for a heat engine to be very
efficient you want to operate at high
temperature but of course this is you
know your your skin temperature is not
much hotter than than room temperature
doesn't matter though you can still
generate milliwatts of power depending
on what you're trying to do it so so for
our SmartWatch that's fantastic so I
think thermoelectrics have a very
promising role to play for these types
of devices I think you know there's
never going to be one silver bullet
you're you could probably leverage a
couple of you can leverage
thermoelectric with PV for example or
kaizo there's nothing wrong with that in
fact it would make sense so I'm gonna
get close to wrapping things up here
with a little demo of a prototype that
we've built at solution you know we we
think we've kind of done and gotten out
of the really hard part I mean there's
still a ton of challenges and and and
and things left to be done when we
werenít word we're still nowhere near
the finish line but in terms of figuring
out the market figuring out the
technology I think we've done a lot of
heavy lifting and and that's where you
know you get to sort of where I think
we're at viability and so this is the
last part of the talk this is a little
simple prototype that basically operates
off your body heat it turns on an LCD
display that tell
the time we've got a MC you in here and
you know the whole works that turns us
on so you can see that the screen is off
right right just for the people in the
front here the screen is off okay so I'm
gonna put this on and hopefully it'll
work I was getting nervous on this part
so I'm sorry of the dead the time is
correct because we have a rechargeable
battery in here there goes it turns on
and I mean it's the time is probably a
little bit off I don't know if yeah it's
did saying it's two-thirty so it's it's
off but this so it turned on and that
was directly due to my body heat if I
take it off there's some latent heat so
it'll stay on for a little bit but as
soon as it turns off I'll show you I'll
just leave it here it's still on right
now again as I said there's a little bit
of latent heat but it's remarkable right
you can power a SmartWatch just from
your body heat without having to ever
worry about recharging the battery for
you know some applications I think you
you know you made a good point right i
mean we've made demos without batteries
in them to show that you can we've
actually made a demo or you light up an
LED that's a two-and-a-half milliwatts
without a battery it's just got a
capacitor you always want you know we're
always going to want some sort of energy
storage because when you take this
device off your body you want to be able
to retain memory right you don't want
the user to have to redo the time for
example so you know I've really gotta
thank my team I mean special my
co-founder Douglas who's been through
you know has been with me for the last
four years and through through it all I
think we've got a really strong team
that I'm really really proud of the
watch is off so yeah
excuse me we've got high phone and an
and Martin we've just hired our six
person p a fellow who's got a PhD from
MIT who's joining februari 8 you know
we've just been we've been doing this
for some time until we really feel like
we've got it to where to where I think
we can you know make an impact in the
marketplace and and at that I thanks a
lot thank you all for your attention and
I'm happy to answer any questions yeah
so first this example you had in the
sound of it it was relying solely on
electric for power which was sorry to
them if you just askin oh this product
like a power source the bones developer
filling in storage essentially also plug
it in to charge it for example if you
want to do that pray that you would just
yeah it's it's basically it's being
powered by the body yeah because I guess
is that because it when I've seen
previous of every cabin for various IOT
applications they're often a hybrid
structure are you also hurting my kind
of thing um so when you can you just
keep can you just specify which me about
hybrid structure charge it and then you
use the end together or it's moving and
for charities
okay um I mean I think it depends on the
application ideally you wouldn't want to
have it wired I mean if you give you if
you could wire it then why would you
need energy harvesting and then maybe
I'm missing your your question the point
of you question it just needs it last
doesn't change me longer actually well
you know that's why if it's wired me or
okay oh yeah okay sorry i think it was
confused by a question yeah no no
absolutely i mean there are gonna be
some applications where you know for a
low power device you can you never have
to recharge the battery for other
applications for other devices that are
power more power hungry you can
absolutely extend battery life which is
a pretty nice as up is already a nice
thing I mean we've we've had a lot of
people tell us that you know you can
extend the battery life of this one
device just by thirty percent that's
already a big deal so I is that make
sense yes variation between people
everything whether oh yeah oh my god
yeah it helps tremendously yeah that's a
great question so the interation with
people where we're doing those studies
actually I mean we don't have enough
statistics so I can give you an answer
right between male-female older younger
but we hope to get to get those
variations you know sometime this year
in terms of temperature yeah i can i can
i can tell you pretty confidently what
we've seen because i didn't mention this
we actually built a little SD card lager
so basically you have your device you
know your thermoelectric it's on your
wrist and just next to it is this we
bought it from a different bunch of
maker companies right you know a Coulomb
counter SD card reader and it's just
basically measuring how much current
you're producing as saving it to an SD
card and at the end of day you can just
put in your computer and plot yeah the
current that you've put you've produced
when you go out on a cold day you can
generate a lot of power licious to say
let's just say that
if it's hot the power drops
significantly the interesting thing is
well let's talk offline I I guess I
don't want to give a give because as
being yeah solar would be nice but
there's actually another thing you can
do and maybe we should talk about
offline I'd rather not yeah oh so that's
where I was getting to and the short
answer is yes but again I can share the
details offline inverter is right right
yeah can you compare the guy
commercially available for anything I
can you lift what you have i become you
tried put in that in the same watch and
comparing the current at the same
voltage four versus four thermoelectric
vs okay oh i see like the incumbent
material and yeah great question um why
don't I answer that offline there's
something you know I i apologize i don't
want to be rude but there's some
proprietary so i'm so happy that i
answered offline yeah i don't want it on
camera thank you but back to your sorry
back to your question i'll get to you it
you know if you're in the northeast on a
winter day it's this thing is it's just
great you know it produces a lot of
juice yeah people looked at like thermal
rectifiers or the nanocrystals to reduce
the yeah that's a great question I mean
that's still in the realm of research
but there are there are thermal
rectifiers out there there are there
actually commercially available some
thermal rectifiers that are commercially
available that's more on the dissipation
the midterm electric material side which
is I think what you're referring to it's
still in the in the realm of research so
people are doing fun on a crystals at a
few places and the idea there for maybe
some of you who don't know is you create
a band gap for the phones so just like
you know semiconductor there's band gaps
for electrons where you know they can't
occupy energy levels the same same for
phonons and that reduces
the thermal connectivity that can reduce
potential its thermal conductivity
tremendously but it's still in the realm
of research yeah your example watch
thing that the bracelet looks very heavy
duty yeah that what that might be
because it's trying to gather as much
heat area as possible effect here
there's a certain area where heat is
flowing from your skin through some
channel but to an outside radiator how
much of that is input and radiator how
much what is the operative area that the
collector is actually just also to when
you know when wet at the end here you
can come up and see it the collector is
just underneath the the watch face and
then the rest of the band is the
dissipation the only reason this is
really bulky and kind of crude looking
is because you know some of this is just
was just machined off the shelf and we
actually have a prototype that's coming
out in a few months that we've
contracted out to an industrial design
firm that's going to look a lot nicer
whatever weather is how many square
inches of skin yeah ask me in contact
with the inside of that yeah I I think
this is about I think this is about
maybe three centimeters by three
centimeters roughly yeah in this case
but it's hard it's hard to give you a
definitive answer because I mean it
really depends what you what you want to
do and you know this is our gen Z Ro
device things are just going to get
better over time where's the other end
of the contact so the collection is
through this face and then the heat
dissipation is through the band no fins
don't you get cooling fins with that oh
yeah great question we can talk about it
offline haha blood temperature
then you know it's interesting that your
core obviously doesn't change right
because we're warm-blooded mammals but
your skin temperature can change
significantly I mean there can be wild
variations in fact if you're outside on
a cold day and you go inside a warm
building you know the warm air is going
to be hotter than your skin temperature
your skin's gonna be really cold I mean
there can be up to 10 degree temp swings
in temperature on your skin even though
your core body is at 37 degrees Celsius
you look at this implants because yes
yeah it's great we have I mean we
haven't looked at it closely but you
know for example pacemaker runs off 30
micro watts of power so very low power
device until they want yeah well no no
I'm talking on average so that dining
that it that includes the the you know
the duty cycling of the very little duty
cycle right i mean it's about a second
right the internal different really yeah
yeah that's right so so let's be clear
for both devices you still want a
battery okay the the problem is the
battery has to be replaced every five to
ten years and that's a surgery believe
it or not now you know unfortunately
people that have these devices typically
don't live five or ten years but you
know even then right there's still
majority there's still a lot that do and
you'd like to avoid having a surgery to
replace the battery right so going back
to your point on you know that the scan
and have you position so people have
done studies and rabbits where you can
actually a position to thermoelectric
next to a warm blood artery you know and
and your skin right is a little bit
cooler right and it's actually we like
to joke that it would probably be even
easier to do an implantable you know
we're not for the not enough of you know
for the fda regulations of course i have
to still pass but that temperature
difference is gonna be constant right
it's not going to fluctuate whether you
go outside or inside you know on a cold
day hot day whatever so yeah yeah the
short answer is absolutely that is it
could be possible hearing aids are
another thing that might be interesting
but
even simpler where you have to worry
about FDA regulations and even
aesthetics is like a medical armband
that a lot of different companies are
trying to give to the market that do
pulse oximetry EKG lots of real estate
you know you don't have to make it look
nice and the battery life there is is
very low it's very short and so the
nurse has to change the battery every
like 12 hours which is a you know it's a
big pain point so there's a lot of
applications potentially down the road
in medical that we see ya in a bracelet
application does it be a problem with
the conductivity because this sliding
around is would you be better off gluing
it yeah I mean it would be money it
would be but yeah spikes yeah I mean
there definitely will be issues right of
its if it's loose and moving around you
know it's got to be making contact to
your skin in order to maximize the
amount of heat coming in so you know you
know maybe in our first generation
device you know maybe we'll have two in
the instruction manual you know keep
tight on your skin right double sided
sticky tape I'm Harry so that might that
might hurt you know when you take it off
with ya your ghosting on wearables and
very good this scale to sort of boys
your remote research areas or ghosts or
authoritarian yeah yeah absolutely i
mean there's a company that just got
acquired it's a canadian company it did
for gensets so for like oil well as
natural gas pipeline monitoring these
were like in the hinterlands of canada
where you know you don't want a guy
going and changing like like you know
adding fuel to the or or or you know
changing a battery or whatever so it
would just basically just take some of
the natural gas stream burn it and
generate a power through a
thermoelectric that way and it would
just power the entire remote monitoring
station and those those things last for
like you know decades write this as long
as long as you have that natural gas
flow and and your monitor i mean i don't
really know what they monitor but i'm
sure
it's a lot of different data right that
they're getting and so that type of you
know market exists it's a very small
market right it's very very small
drilling right oil drilling that could
be a potential another potential one
where you know you have this oil drill
and it gets there's a lot of sensors on
it and you know there's issues with
getting power down there I mean is it's
small markets though so that's why I
don't know do you have something in mind
that that might go yeah yeah yeah yeah
sure yeah definitely I think definitely
doable and in fact people are doing it
right is there a reason you chose to
nanostructure the silicon it's the just
like the defects in wolf's clothing yeah
um okay great question and and and I
don't know how much I want to reveal but
you know you can do it to both ways and
you know I'll leave it at that but but
the name of the game is right if you
look at I don't know how familiar are
with with the field most people in
thermoelectrics take bulk so looking and
they crush it into like a powder they
try to ball mill it for example where
you literally just throw bulk
semiconductors like business higher and
Teller bismuth telluride into a machine
that basically has a bunch of ball
bearings and it just rotates and it just
you know the little ball bearings hit
the semi conductor material and kind of
like break it up into nanoparticles and
then they take that powder make into a
slurry and kind of compacted and heat it
up and and now you've got this like bulk
semiconductor that's got these little
nano crystalline grains that scatter
photons and lower thermal conductivity
that way so so definitely I mean that
that's a huge in fact most researchers
researchers in the field are doing
things like that so so it's definitely
in it definitely interesting
no Ariel
so can you can you scan yuscavage if we
had a taxi services it don't live in all
the manufacturing of silicon can you use
any silicon or is it or or young or do
you care yeah I know I I think I think
you could we have not tried right now we
do everything single I'm single crystal
on waivers but you could absolutely do I
think I think so yeah I think it's
possible you just haven't tried it back
when they had scrapped right
Oh
you